the president's top military advisors
are talking about what they know and
don't know about Russia's so-called
bounty on US forces in Afghanistan the
Secretary of Defense of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff Chairman also talked about the
use of the military to deal with
civilian disturbances chief
congressional correspondent Mike Emanuel
shows us today's testimony before the
House Armed Services Committee the
Secretary of Defense and chairman of the
Joint Chiefs were pressed on the
military's role in recent protests in
Washington DC
including clearing Lafayette Park near
the White House June 1st still unclear
to me who gave the direction to clear
the park at that moment in time see I
find that hard to believe
I'm sorry but it's like the pretty big
decision a lot of people there
everyone's there and it just sort of
happened
Esper noted and what have been described
as peaceful protests 50 Park Police 60
Secret Service and six National Guard
soldiers were injured including one who
was hit in the head with a brick
but Esper cautioned against bringing in
active duty soldiers using active duty
forces in a direct law enforcement role
should remain a last resort general
Milley weighed in on the broader
societal issues we as a nation and as a
military are still struggling with
racism and we have much work to do Nili
also took aim at the Civil War
Confederate names on military bases
issue was an act of treason at the time
against the Union against the Stars and
Stripes against the US Constitution and
those officers turn their back on their
own some lawmakers are also focused on
recent reporting from the New York Times
and others on leaked intelligence the
russians offered Afghan fighters a
bounty to kill US troops have you
received a Intel briefing that include
the word bounty with respect to Russians
and the killing of American and women in
uniform congressman to the best of my
recollection I have not received a
briefing that included the word bounty
merely told lawmakers the Russians have
been meddling in Afghanistan since
probably 2013 he promised if it's true
Russia has a bounty program the US will
take action John my commando force
tonight washing
Mike thanks so much